a new study highlights potentially
dangerous interactions between
herbal supplements and prescription
medications researchers looked at dozens
of reports of serious drug interactions
among patients with disorders like high
blood pressure diabetes cancer and
depression and they found herbal
supplements may affect medications
effectiveness or have side effects more
than half of Americans say they take
dietary and herbal supplements including
ginkgo biloba ginseng or st. John's wort
up to one in four adults report taking
supplements and prescription drugs at
the same time and many don't ask their
doctor if it's safe our dr. taryn Rula
is here with why the combination can be
risky good morning good morning John
what is the greatest risk here of this
mixing or of not telling your doctor at
all so for most Americans who are about
to take their gingko biloba as you
mentioned they're thinking that it's to
enhance their health they're thinking
it's natural it must be safe they're not
thinking about risk but the fact of the
matter is that herbal supplements are
pharmacologically active they're
biologically active so they can do
things like change your blood sugar your
blood pressure your cholesterol promote
bleeding so the the idea that that could
interact with medication also exists
meaning that if you're trying to treat a
condition and now these herbal
supplements have their own innate
effects you may be working for or
against the condition you're trying to
treat number one but number two through
kind of how they affect the liver and
the liver metabolism they can alter the
amount of drug in your system to either
make their levels higher of the
prescription drug you're taking or lower
okay so let's get specific what types of
these supplements can can affect we're
talking about things like st. John's
wort ginseng ginkgo biloba cranberry
green tea there's a whole host of them
and so to give you an example if you're
a cardiac patient and you're taking a
blood thinner like coumadin and then
you're taking a specific herbal
supplement that could either make the
coumadin levels higher or lower in your
system which means you'll be maybe more
likely to bleed or that you may be more
likely to clot if you're taking a statin
you may be more likely to have muscle
aches or pain if you're a cancer patient
on chemotherapy it may not be as
effective the chemotherapy of your
antidepressants it may make you more
depressed I know that was interesting I
think that interaction for a lot of
people because I think insane
is very very popular these are things
that people don't often think about but
why do you think patients don't want to
tell their doctors that they're taking
herbal supplements in the first place
this is such a big issue I can't tell
you 90% of the people I ask they tell me
that they are taking some form of a
supplement but it's only when I ask if
you look at the medication list you say
what medications are you taking they
don't bring it up and whether it's
because they don't think that it's
important or because they don't want to
the doctor to tell them don't take that
I'm not sure but the reality is it's
important because you need that open
dialogue to discuss the pros any proven
health benefits to taking these herbal
supplements so we don't really have the
data to submit we don't have the science
and in this country we don't get
educated in the medical profession about
it but no doubt that there are probably
some benefits but you have to weigh them
with the risks all right and talk to
your doctor and please tell you please
doctor doctor thank you dr. Terry